six one seven eight three zero 4750 why
don't we go next to our caller from the
708 area code caller from 708 Iran with
us hello David my name is Barry can you
hear me
yeah we can hear you fine all right it's
honor to be on your show I want to ask
you a question kind of about the me2
movement and changing perceptions about
sexual assault oh there was a case at my
college were basically a girl told she
basically said because this guy
encouraged her to have sex and she
decided to do it that she felt coerced
into it and then the college basically
decided to suspend the guy for it and so
I guess my question is is there any
problems with how we think about sexual
assault after the age of Trump do you
think that people are taking it too far
it's just one of these extreme cases
well listen I don't know the details of
the case I don't know what it means that
this girl was coerced right I mean I
wasn't I couldn't possibly adjudicate
that particular case what are the things
that I can tell you right what I can
tell you are a few different things
number one there has been massive stigma
around coming forward and saying that
one has been sexually assaulted and one
of the positive effects of the me2
movement is that it has at least taken
steps towards making victims somewhat
more comfortable and willing to come
forward and say hey I was a victim
myself that's number one number two the
92 movement has also exposed that not
all sexual harassment and sexual assault
are the same thing this is not a defense
of any particular action but there is a
major major difference in what Harvey
Weinstein is accused of what Donald
Trump is accused of what Kevin Spacey is
accused of what Aziz Ansari was you know
in in trouble in the media for having
done so I think it's also important to
recognize that not all of this stuff is
the same and that's something that not
everybody is sort of that eager to sort
of acknowledge and then in the back of
that is this sort of what I think big
picture is a red herring which are the
eye
isolated cases that exist in any system
where you have either false assertions
or confusion around what is really being
denounced or whatever every system that
is a worthwhile system is going to have
some people that misuse the system
social welfare benefits social welfare
benefits over all can be hugely
beneficial to society and help lift
people out of poverty there will be some
freeriders does the fact that there are
some free riders mean we throw the
system away no there have always been
some either false accusers or people who
are maybe coerced into making an
allegation this is not a massive problem
statistically we want to make sure that
everybody that is convicted or punished
for sexual assault has actually done
that which they're accused of but I
don't know that there's any like
overarching revelations because of a
case that as you say may be a
questionable case and again I've not
heard of the case I couldn't possibly
comment on it all right that that was a
completely reasonable answer thank you
for your time and all the work you're
doing thank you really appreciate the
call you know I have to say Pat we
talked yesterday about whether we're
gonna do away with live calls but it's
actually not a bad series of live calls
today I think that we actually did okay
today yeah I think that's the redemption
right I think live calls may be here to
stay from this point on but yeah we'll
have to hear from the audience yeah yeah
yesterday's segment was was pretty
brutal as far as live calls go but maybe
some people were swayed by this week's
live calls sorry to everybody we didn't
get to I know there are still more than
a dozen people holding but we are out of
time but we will take live calls again